well welcome to this video and this is a
nice one I'm playing a club mate of mine
or teammate of mine so um let's see I
think it's the first game i have on
video against him so c5 let's let's see
okay let's play some non theoretical
stuff we know our opening some pretty
well i mean we know what the other is
playing so it's often a good idea to to
get some some different kind of setup ok
let's play a color set up it's not
exactly dangerous but I don't feel very
much like discussing some some main line
that we analyzed years ago or something
ok it transposes to UM aha it transposed
to a very open position if I freely I
thought maybe after this ayah what has
something I always thought but ok just
taking only form I was expecting hmm
interesting
okay of course I am not really an expert
on this opening it was just played here
to to get some some different kind of
position that we don't know down low
from analysis that we M did together so
I'm gather the big big tension in the
center now Joe yep don't like it but
what this my move here e takes d5 you
can take on d4 with the night this looks
I'm somewhat somewhat annoying yeah
maybe I don't have any other move don't
really um see something great at the
moment of course the Sam this looks of
completely alright for black
now the d5 pawn looks am rather weak I
can just play the bishop edge 540 yeah
and it's not clear what what is what my
next move g4 of courses are really
really weakening booth but how do i how
do I procedure don't really see how to
untie the piece of a move the night I've
got a really ugly looking porn okay come
on let's let's do this it really looks
looks like a good game for black but I
don't see how much else ok and then
takes only five erdf fire haha yeah it
can learn this can get really really
ugly I don't turn I don't really have
any decent development yeah I suspect
that this failed some due to more than
one more than one continuation but um
what what can you do yeah this is some
rather simplistic so maybe all right
we have six I can play 94 at least maybe
this is some still playable at least if
I go what what what happens now what
happens if I go 95 Queen somewhere Queen
f4 Wow let's prove let's play some I
mean win f4 and 93 but Queen a force
probably still all right I didn't really
think about this move
hmm yeah 93 can I def three I mean of
course damn down to 30 seconds what a
disaster this happens if you play some
openings that you really don't know
nothing about yeah I was an instant
trouble somehow after this Bishop g4
move it looked like like I'm already
already worse so it's obviously not so
easy to play this this opening and hope
for some quiet game dad can I can also
resign 20 seconds or so so quite I mean
the position is lost and I'm also i have
no no chance at all to to do something
on time so let's let's resign but let's
have a look at this I'm really curious I
always thought that this should be good
for for at least a bit of something here
but maybe this is a totally wrong wrong
conception I think I think the problem
is the sea pawns I exchanged and this is
this is the difference this is probably
the difference I was thinking about this
I think there is something okay let's
let's get into this together game was so
interesting but it says this this
opening has some points if you look at
this i played this and he poops mmm and
he captured on d4
so there is there's one line rupee one
and after this there's a five as a
possibility and then e 4 and this is in
fact quite quite interesting to play
because if now Bishop g4 note the
difference I can take on d5 and there's
no career night XD for obviously as as
the porn is still on c3 this was this
was the fact that confused me he played
after he formed he took I keep hitting
this from this button and e 50 and down
and now i played this and this leads to
trouble I mean okay this isn't exactly
great but white can always just take
here and there's not not much happening
I mean just just the normal kind of
position I mean this this for example
here so it's probably just just about
equal but Jamie ruka this rookie one
which I thought was good I mean it would
have been good if the bonds were still
on the board but after this I'm already
in big trouble and amazing that that
this can happen so so quickly of course
in this open position it's um it's a
problem that the night is on d to this
is just a much worse post then the night
on on c6 the knight on c6 is just much
more active pressurizing the center and
here in fact it's it's difficult to find
to find some playable move even if I
would take if i take here 95 then it's
just just ugly what what are you doing
now you're in a pin and this piece is
hanging if you would figure go here it's
just it's just very very ugly
like it's just much better this will
cost a porn in the long run the upon an
intern yeah you don't have just 94 is
the big threat and down so I cannot play
some some zero move but what I did was I
took and 94 and now this is just
terrible g5 is just just a very weak
pawn and okay this was already a bit of
a desperation attempt yeah the computer
just wants to go 95 which is what I
expected but this is probably also
interesting yeah here um i'm probably
back in the game a computer actually
likes right now but okay it's it's
really just um he just needs to take
here and there's not a for coming and
i'm just toast I don't have I don't have
a move even like it's just much better
developed tune two brilliant nights and
I've full of full of weaknesses so just
just the disaster but maybe you still
got something out of this game this
opening here is this a good setup for
black against the collar and
here take note that of this this idea
which is interesting I didn't didn't
know I'm that that this is possible
after the capture unknown deform and
obviously it's quite okay for black and
what can easily go astray f if we just
what we're just witness here yeah thanks
for watching